SPEAKER 1: So the best
way to experience a video
API is through a live demo.
And let's start by taking
this video of a Super Bowl
commercial for Google Home.
And I'm going to play
the first few seconds.
We can see that it starts
with a mountain landscape.
And we see a house,
a city street,
then it goes to a
dog, and a garage.
So lots of scene changes
happening in this video.
And if we were to
manually categorize
what was happening
throughout it,
we need to watch
the entire thing
and write down what was
happening in every scene.
Luckily, the video API
takes care of this for us
with just a single
REST API request.
So it tells us two things.
One, at a high level, it tells
us what is this video about.
And then it also tells us,
in a more granular level,
what labels it finds in
the video in each scene.
So if we scroll down here, we
can see it identifies a dog,
and it can tell us exactly where
in the video that dog appears.
It also identifies--
at the end of the video
there's a birthday cake.
And if we scroll
down a bit more,
we can see that, not only
does it know it's a dog,
it knows what type of dog it is.
That it's a dachshund.
And if we scroll down through
the rest of the labels,
we can see that it also
successfully identifies
that mountain pass scene
from the beginning.
So this is what the API
can do with one video.
But you likely have
more than one video
that you want to analyze.
So let's take a look at
how a company might use
the video intelligence, API.
A media publisher
could have hundreds
of petabytes of video data
sitting in storage buckets.
And one common thing
they might want to do
is create a highlight
reel focused
on a specific type of content.
Or search their large library
for a specific entity.
So let's see how we would use
the video intelligence, API,
to search a large library of
videos, given all this metadata
that we get back from it.
So we've got a lot
of videos here.
And let's say this
media publisher has
hours of sports
video, but they only
want to find the content
relevant to baseball.
So let's go ahead and
search our library here
for baseball videos.
And we can see that
not only does it
show us which videos
have baseball,
it tells us exactly when in
those videos baseball appears.
My favorite example is this one.
We have this video, which only
has a tiny bit about baseball,
but it's able to identify
that clip for us.
Whereas, if we were
to manually do this,
we'd have to watch the
whole video looking
for that specific scene.
So if we click on
the scene, we can
see that this is from last
year's year end search video
when the Cubs won
the World Series.
So let's do one more search.
I live on the East Coast, where
it's pretty cold right now.
I've heard there's been a ton
of rain in SF this past year.
I think we can all agree it'd
be pretty nice to be on a beach
right now.
And while machine learning
can't take us there,
it can do the next best thing.
And find all the beach clips
in our video library for us.
So let's search for
our beach videos.
And then we can click to
all of our beach clips
in the videos below.
So as you saw through this demo,
the video intelligence, API,
makes it easy to quickly
and easily understand
a large library
of video content.
Something that was
almost impossible
just a few months ago.
Tasks that used
to take hours, now
take seconds with the
video intelligence, API.
And I'm excited to make it
available to all of you today.
Thank you.